más de 10.000 migrantes están estancados
en el norte de colombia concretamente en
el municipio de necoclí un pueblo de tan
sólo 40.000 habitantes nunca antes
habían llegado tantas personas a esta
costa que suele ser el lugar de paso de
africanos asiáticos y latinoamericanos
los migrantes son tantos que están
asignados en las playas esperando tomar
un bote por las aguas del mar caribe
para luego intentar atravesar la difícil
selva del darién llegar a panamá y
continuar su camino hacia el norte esta
vez la mayoría son viajeros yo pido a la
autoridad colombiano que mete mano a ver
cómo despacha en el grupo que están acá
y que espera que reciben otro grupo eso
lo único que yo pido en enero de este
año el pueblo colombiano también se
desbordó cuando miles de migrantes
quedaron atrapados tras el cierre de las
fronteras a causa de la pandemia pero
esta vez es diferente porque no hay un
cierre forzoso y la cantidad de
migrantes pone en jaque la capacidad
sanitaria y económica de necoclí un
pueblo azotado históricamente por la
guerra y la pobreza
preocupado porque se nos puede presentar
en estos momentos una calamidad bien sea
de salud pública o un brote más se
venimos en confinamiento del hobby la
situación es tal que el gobierno local
de necoclí declaró calamidad pública los
migrantes están atrapados porque los
traficantes a los que les pagan sólo
transportan una cantidad de personas
insuficiente frente a los cerca de 1.000
extranjeros que llegan cada día su mayor
aspiración es encontrar un país que los
acoja